has notado cómo es el movimiento de las
manecillas del reloj siempre se mueven
hacia el mismo lado y nunca dejan de
girar vamos a ponerle atención a la
manecilla de los minutos si empezamos en
el 12 cuando vuelva a pasar por ahí ya
habrá dado un giro completo entonces
cuando llegue el 6 habrá dado medio giro
y si solo recorre del 12 al 3 será un
cuarto de giro cada que avanza tres
números la manecilla forma un cuarto de
giro cuando se encuentran dos líneas de
esta manera se forma un ángulo has visto
este ángulo que se forma con un cuarto
de giro en algún otro lado yo lo ha
visto en las esquinas de los cuadrados y
de los rectángulos estas figuras se
forman con cuatro ángulos tú puedes
hacer un ángulo con tu cuerpo solo
tienes que ponerte de pie y levantar tu
brazo hasta que esté súper derechito
justo así ves se formó un ángulo al
mover tu brazo igual que el cuarto de
giro en el reloj si levantas el otro
el movimiento es hacia el otro lado en
sentido contrario a las manecillas del
reloj pero sigue formándose un ángulo
siempre que haya dos líneas que se unan
en un punto se formará un ángulo con tus
piernas puedes formar líneas de este
tipo y encontrar ángulos cuando te
levantas y separas un poco tus pies el
movimiento que haces es formar un ángulo
piensa en tus piernas como las líneas
que se juntan el ángulo que formas es un
poco más pequeño que el ángulo de un
cuarto de giro en el reloj o incluso al
ir caminando vas formando ángulos con tu
cuerpo mira cómo se forma este ángulo
con tus piernas justo cuando marcas un
paso formas un ángulo de un cuarto de
giro además de nuestro cuerpo podemos
mover objetos y formar ángulos con ellos
y hasta puedes encontrar ángulos en los
objetos sin necesidad de moverlos cuando
lees un libro lo más común es abrirlo
hasta un poco antes de formar una línea
horizontal que sería medio giro o tú más
como abren los libros cuando les fijate
como dependiendo de qué tanto abras un
libro se van formando diferentes ángulos
al irlo abriendo tenemos un ángulo de
menos de un cuarto de giro cuando llega
a la parte alta tenemos un cuarto de
giro después lo abrimos más y el ángulo
es mayor a un cuarto de giro y cuando lo
colocamos sobre alguna mesa y queda
extendido
tenemos un ángulo de medio giro no
importa si lo abres mucho poquito
estamos formando ángulos es increíble la
cantidad de objetos y movimientos con
las que podemos formar y encontrar
ángulos prueba colocando dos lápices y
mueve los sin separar las puntas
es divertido cierto cada movimiento es
un ángulo diferente por más cosas en
movimiento y descubre ángulos en donde
menos pensabas porque los ángulos están
en todos lados